and so are you writing and then emailing
him notes
are you meeting in person like how how
does this work when
both oh okay yeah yeah sometimes uh we
would get together and
uh what todd todd used to love when
i would uh basically perform what i had
come up with
you know he would he'd sit back with his
glass of wine and i'd put mine down
and i would act out i would act out
these new ideas oh that's interesting
well
you know this is something also that i i
when i when i teach classes
in in screenwriting or whatever um uh
i one of the things i always try to
to make aspiring screenwriters
understand is
it isn't first of all it's not just
about you know
watching movies i hear a lot of people
go well i watch a lot of movies so i
know
that i know how movies work and i was
like well no you don't
watching movies is great and you should
do that but you got to do way more than
that
and it's not just i think it's more than
just
reading uh books about writing
i think it's much more than that because
you're dealing in a medium that
uh it's much it's way more than just um
your words yeah you know you you have
actors who then have to say those words
so
i always recommend screenwriters take an
acting class
um i think my background in acting
i mean i was a theater major at college
so i did a lot of acting
a lot of stage work um and then i did
the horror movies in canada
that has helped me write dialogue
because
i can tell as an actor if that's a line
that i'm going to be able to say
i think that it if you can understand
how an actor looks at a line
it'll help you write a better line for
that actor
can you give me some examples i like
that let's say it's the scene where
the kids showing up at the wedding i'm
sure you had different
ways of him kind of you know the whole
like if anyone here objects i think you
told me that yeah
so yeah but but were there other sort of
ways you were planning on doing it and
you
acted it out and realized yeah no they
wouldn't say it like this they would say
it like this
yeah i well what i do is
i try to assign in my head
a voice for each character right now
sometimes it'll be
the voice of an an actor that i know
right i mean not personally or just you
know i'm i've
seen movies with that actor so like when
we made hugh grant at one point when we
were making him british
i had hugh grant's voice in my head so
it was a lot easier to write that
dialogue
hearing it coming from his voice in here
you know
um and then the acting um the acting out
part of it
is um i i must have looked like a
crazy person because derek one of the
one of the apartments that we lived in
back then um was on the third floor
of in in like toluca lake area
uh of this apartment building and there
was a little tiny
office at the top of it a little tiny
office and there was a uh
there was an access door to the roof
right
and back then i would stay i could stay
up all night writing
i i was just i was more of a night owl
back then not anymore not so much
anymore
but i would i'd come up with a scene or
it'd be close to getting a scene
and it'd be two o'clock in the morning
and i'd go outside out onto the roof
and i'd be walking around up there
talking to myself like acting out the
part
and yeah and and trying to come up with
the dialogue that would be true to the
character
and not be too expositional which is
something that
all of us screenwriters must avoid
uh and and see if it worked see if it
worked just
at least you know out loud or or in my
head
and that's what i would finally
commit to and sometimes the character
would change
voices um if it wasn't working um
my for for the amazing fabular um i was
telling you earlier that
he was you know the psychic in my head
as
i was writing it it was um jonathan
harris
um who was dr smith on lost in space the
old tv series
and he was very flamboyant and so both
you know
and uh and that was the voice in my head
but when
um when we went to make the movie
and and titus burgess got the role
um he didn't want to play it like that
because that he felt like that was too
close to a character that he plays on
the unbreakable it can be schmidt
so he wanted to downplay him a little
more you know and it so
i remember the first couple of days on
set i was very lucky by the way
that john asher allowed me to be on set
every day
oh that's great um and and consulted
with me
from time to time um he always had the
final word of course because he's the
director it's
not my movie anymore it's his you know
but um
titus did not want to play i just didn't
want to play
him the way i had written it or at least
how the voice in my head had written it
um and so that took a couple of days for
me to get used to
and in the end it worked out fine but
those first couple of days i was just
like oh
shouldn't i ash pulled asher aside and
it's just like like sneaky bigger
and everything like that and um but i
i think it also those first couple of
days were that were difficult for titus
because
literally day one first day day one
that morning the emmy nominations were
announced and he was nominated which
means that
that whole day he was getting his phone
must have been just blowing up from his
all of his agents and his managers and
his friends and his family all calling
him and
you know saying congratulations anything
like that so i think he was a little
a little distracted this first first day
or so but um
but uh you know in the end it's it's a
he gave a great performance
and i'm you know very very happy
that that he was involved and he played
played the role
you